politique le soutien financier du Fonds
citoyen franco-allemand
en France depuis septembre 2020 on va
évoquer avec vous plusieurs sujets dans
cette émission l'évolution des relations
franco-allemandes depuis l'arrivée de la
scholls au pouvoir l'investissement
historique de l'Allemagne aussi dans son
armée les conséquences du conflit entre
la Russie et l'Ukraine en Europe nous
allons parler aussi tout au long de cet
entretien des différents types de
coopération
franco-allemandes mais d'abord on va
revenir sur l'actualité qui va marquer
donc l'hiver la crise énergétique avant
la guerre en Ukraine l'Allemagne
importait 55% de son gaz de Russie alors
comment est-ce que l'Allemagne va-t-elle
faire maintenant pour donc remplacer ce
gaz russe c'est-à-dire l'Allemagne a
déjà considérablement réduit ces
exportations en matière de du gaz russe
du pétrole russe du charbon russe en ce
qui concerne le charbon donc c'est c'est
fini mais en ce qui concerne le gaz
aussi
finir à cause de des problèmes de du gaz
et du gnost stream donc on a on a on a
pris des mesures très importantes
maintenant il faut remplacer le gaz le
pétrole Chavant en russe on le fait on
est important du par exemple du gaz
naturel liquéfié mais en même temps il
faut aussi réduire la consommation en
gaz et en pétrole et ça on fait
également la relance de centrale à
charbon vous en parler c'est une mesure
vitale en ce moment mais très mauvaise
pour l'environnement pourtant
l'Allemagne s'est engagé avec l'Union
européenne a appliquer le Green Deal
finalement ce qui est l'Allemagne n'est
pas coincé entre l'impératif énergétique
et l'urgence climatique
bon c'est une c'est une mesure
transitoire vous l'avez dit juste titre
donc il faut le faire maintenant parce
que
donc il y a un manque de
gaz de charbon russe et d'où la
nécessité vraiment de rouvrir donc les
centrales les centrales à charbon mais
c'est une usure transitoire ce qu'on
fait maintenant en même temps en effort
énorme n'est-ce pas pour renforcer les
énergies renouvelables puis à cet accord
aussi franco-allemand pour mieux passer
l'hiver donc les Allemands consomment 85
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz par an
pour faire tourner leur industrie contre
41 milliards pour les Français presque
donc deux fois moins Emmanuel Macron et
olafles ont donc conclué un accord pour
que la France et l'Allemagne donc pour
que la France exporte du gaz à son
voisin allemand contre de l'électricité
en échange car nous nous manquons
d'électricité plusieurs centrales ont
été mises en pause notamment pour être
donc
pour être
pour avoir sur les 26 réacteurs sur les
56 ils devront progressivement être
remis en route pendant l'hiver c'est un
accord gagnant-gagnant entre la France
et l'Allemagne je pense que c'est une
belle exemple de la solidarité
mais pour nos deux nations et se posent
la question donc
comment surmonter ces difficultés
pendant l'hiver qui qui vient il me
semble que cette cet accord entre un
code principe entre le chancelier et le
président en public la France si
nécessaire va livrer du gaz et
l'Allemagne va livrer de l'excès c'est
une belle exemple la solidarité
franco-allemande dans une situation très
très difficile mais
je pense que que des détails restent
encore réglés autre conséquence du
conflit en Ukraine c'est l'inflation en
Allemagne elle a atteint 10,8% entre
septembre 2021 et septembre 2022 le
gouvernement a annoncé la mise en place
d'un bouclier tarifaire qui bénéficiera
donc au consommateur mais aussi aux
entreprises 200 milliards au lâcheuse à
surnommé ce plan double vroom pour donc
relancer le moteur économique allemand
l'objectif c'est d'éviter un maximum les
faillites d'entreprise
le but c'est paquet est vraiment de
réduire
le niveau des prix énergétiques
c'est-à-dire
pour le gaz pour pour l'électricité
c'est une mesure qui est tout à fait
nécessaire et qui vise a vraiment donc
réduire donc les conséquences pour les
ménages pour les particuliers ainsi que
pour l'industrie donc de cette flambeau
des prix énergétiques les principaux
institués économiques allemands table
sur une récession de 0,4% pour l'année
2023 en Allemagne il faut s'attendre à
une année difficile pour les Allemands
et pour l'Union européenne
oui ce sera une univers difficile mais
aussi une année difficile
2023 donc ça reste à voir si ça donc
s'il y aura vraiment une récession de ça
dépend un peu de circonstances c'est
très difficile à prévoir mais il faut
bien se préparer maintenant d'où la
nécessité de prendre ses mesures que
vous avez mentionnées c'est-à-dire de ce
paquet de 2000 de 2 milliards d'euros
pour protéger les ménages les
consommateurs mais aussi les entreprises
cet été déjà pour lutter contre
l'augmentation des prix du carburant
l'Allemagne a mis en place un ticket
mensuel de 9 euros pour les transports
en commun selon l'association allemande
des transports en commun VDV cela a
permis d'éviter les missions de 1,8
millions de tonnes de CO2 alors quel
bilan faites-vous de cette mesure qui a
été prise pendant cet été est-ce que ça
peut être un bon outil à réutiliser dans
les prochains mois
il me semble que c'était dans les
expériences avec avec l'introduction de
ce ticket à 9 euros c'était c'était très
positifs n'est-ce pas cette mais c'était
aussi une mesure transitoire
c'est maintenant aussi au Lander un peu
de décider si on va continuer cette
mesure par exemple la vie des bananes le
long de Berlin a décidé maintenant de
d'introduire un ticket à 49 euros donc
mais ce sont des des mesures sur un plan
régional qui doivent être prises
maintenant mais généralement c'était une
prise une mesure
réussie mais de l'autre côté donc ça
coûte cher donc cinq glandes chaque
commune doit décider donc si on va
continuer avec ces mesures là toujours
dans les transports l'Allemagne est le
premier pays du monde a lancé une flotte
100% à hydrogène dans la région de
Bassac alors conçu à dans le Sud-Ouest
ils ont ensuite été assemblés dans
l'usine d'Alstom en Allemagne de Sales
digitaire il permettront donc d'éviter
l'émission de 4400 tonnes de CO2 par an
les travails hydrogènes sont des trains
d'avenir pour l'Allemagne et pour
l'Europe
à mon avis c'est une belle exemple de
la coopération industrielle entre la
France et l'Allemagne en matière de donc
des technologies hydrogène c'est
certainement une technologie de futurs
et donc à mon avis c'est vraiment une
belle exemple et
c'est compliqué n'est-ce pas donc la
technologie hydrogène à mon avis mais
c'est en début très encourageant
avant d'être ambassadeur d'Allemagne en
France vous étiez ambassadeur de
l'Allemagne au siège de l'OTAN à
Bruxelles ce conflit justement entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine certains le
justifient car l'OTAN aurait été trop
agressif envers la Russie notamment en
s'élargissant énormément à l'est alors
on parlait déjà d'une potentielle
adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN avant la
guerre mais volo des meilleurs zalinski
a relancé donc cette demande au cours du
conflit est-ce que l'Allemagne soutient
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN
que finalement
l'Ukraine devendant en membre de l'OTAN
c'est une autre question donc
quand ça se passera
pour le moment de notre position est
assez claire qui pour le moment il faut
vraiment se focaliser n'est ce pas sur
le soutien politique économique et aussi
militaire de l'Ukraine dans sa lutte
dans sa défense contre une Russie
agressive impérialiste
et ça c'est maintenant notre focus me
semble que l'adhésion immédiate de
l'Ukraine un notaire c'est pas c'est pas
dans l'ordre du jour
depuis le début du conflit l'Allemagne a
déjà accueilli près de 1 million
d'ukrainien sur son sol ils se sont vus
accordés à un statut de protection dans
le pays donc dans tous les pays de
l'Union européenne selon une directive
c'était pour une durée de trois ans
alors l'Allemagne est réputé pour un
manquer de main d'oeuvre on estime
qu'entre 1,5 et 2 millions de postes se
rêve à Caen s'est réfugiés sont donc
doublement les bienvenus en Allemagne
parce qu'on veut aider le peuple
ukrainien il me semble aussi que cette
chiffre d'admillion c'est tout à fait
impressionnant
et on fait tout ce qu'on peut
probablement pour soutenir
donc les réfugiés de l'autre côté donc
c'est pas toujours facile donc il y a
aussi une discussion maintenant entre
les leders et le gouvernement fédéral
donc qui qui va donc payer pour ces
mesures là donc c'est une c'est une
question qu'il faut qu'il faut régler
mais je pense que on y arrive à
certainement donc il y a une solidarité
impressionnante aussi de la part de la
population allemande avec les réfugiés
ukrainiens et depuis la mobilisation
partielle lancée par Vladimir Poutine de
nombreux Russes souhaitent également
rejoindre les frontières de l'Union
européenne alors qu'il y a les États
membres il y a les pays baltes la
République tchèque notamment qui ne
veulent pas leur offrir des visas
l'Allemagne el milite pour pour les
accueillir
donc qui était qui est une discussion
maintenant
à Bruxelles donc il y a d'un côté
donc la question est-ce qu'on peut
accueillir donc c'est ces gens-là donc
il y a des questions de sécurité qui
doit qu'on doit
clarifier donc c'est une discussion si
continue qui continue donc les
négociations sont toujours en cours
c'est aussi dans ce contexte que
l'Allemagne a annoncé réinvestir
massivement dans son armée un profond
spécial de 100 milliards sera consacré
donc à la Bundes verts Schulz veut en
faire la force armée la mieux équipée
d'Europe alors une formule qui inquiète
ici en France depuis des années
l'équilibre de l'Union européenne c'est
un petit peu elle repose sur un
leadership militaire et diplomatique de
la France et d'un côté contre un
leadership économique de l'Allemagne de
l'autre est-ce que cette cette annonce
ne va pas déséquilibrer un petit peu cet
équilibre européen selon vous j'envoie
pas d'inquiétude ici en France
par contre le gouvernement français a
salué donc c'est ici ses yeux ces gens
du gouvernement allemand de mieux
équipés la Baume de sphère car ce que
nous voulons c'est vraiment bâtir une
Europe de la défense n'est-ce pas
pour faire en sorte que l'Europe soit
capable de
d'assumer ses responsabilités
particulièrement dans son voisinage et
pour pour se faire il faut vraiment
une armée allemande qui qui soit capable
de faire le job n'est-ce pas
malheureusement c'est pas le cas parce
que
pendant les années récentes on n'a pas
suffisamment investi
donc là mais un monde sans sous investi
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement allemand a décidé
on vit aussi donc de la situation
sécurité dramatique n'est-ce pas de
d'augmenter d'une manière massive
n'est-ce pas nos investisseurs en
matière de défense et ça quelque chose
qui a été salué par le gouvernement
français mais aussi par nos partenaires
en Europe y compris aussi donc nos
partenaires aux États-Unis le ministre
français de la Défense Sébastien Lecornu
et la ministre allemande de la défense
Christine Lambret se sont rencontrés le
22 septembre dernier ils ont confirmé la
réalisation des projets Scaff la viande
de combat franco-allemand du futur mais
aussi du char franco-allemand du futur
nous deux pays seront ainsi encore plus
liés en matière de défense
à mon avis ce sont des projets vraiment
très importants les projets
emblématiques car donc ces projets de
montres donc la responsabilité partagée
de la France et de l'Allemagne pour
bâtir cette Europe de la défense ce sont
des projets compliqués
qui nécessitent aussi donc une
négociation mais en fin de compte il me
semble et ce sont vraiment des des
piliers n'est-ce pas d'une Europe de la
défense l'hypnopolitique
les relations franco-allemandes
maintenant avec vous en dire Lucas
ambassadeurs d'Allemagne en France les
relations franco-allemandes sont sans
doute les relations les plus intenses
d'un point de vue diplomatique et de
coopération institutionnelle entre deux
pays après le traité de l'Elysée en 1963
entre Charles de Gaulle et Conrad
Adenauer le traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle en
2019 entrée manuel Macron et nguella
Merkel a réaffirmé et approfondi encore
plus la coopération entre les deux pays
il y a eu notamment depuis ce traité la
création d'un Front citoyen
franco-allemand peuvent charger de
financer des projets citoyens pour
développer du lien entre la France et
l'Allemagne il y a aussi l'ophage
l'Office Franco-Allemand pour la
Jeunesse ça laisse de multiples
possibilités au citoyens et aux jeunes
de s'emparer de cette amitié
franco-allemande aussi absolument donc
où là vous l'avez bien exprimé je pense
que le traite avec sa chapelle encore
élargi le champ d'action
entre la France et l'Allemagne en ce qui
concerne la coopération entre de société
civile y compris la jeunesse et le fond
citoyen donc c'est vraiment à mon avis
une déjà maintenant donc il est clair
que c'est une mesure
initiative très réussie parce qu'avec ce
fond on peut vraiment soutenir beaucoup
de contacts très informel n'est-ce pas
entre des initiatives en France et en
Allemagne donc ça ça a vraiment
c'était une excellente idée donc de
créer ce fond
et en plus n'est ce pas aussi renforcer
donc le travail de l'offrage ça permet
c'est vraiment c'est la base n'est-ce
pas des relations frontalement ce sont
les contacts entre entre les gens entre
les peuples entre les sociétés civiles
ça c'est pour élargir un petit peu cette
amitié qui ne doit pas être que qu'un
institutionnel et que entre guillemets
entre les gouvernements les assemblées
mais que l'ensemble des citoyens
s'emparent aussi de cette question
absolument
à mon avis c'est vraiment le la base de
la de la relation franco-inde et y
compris les jumelages n'est-ce pas entre
entre les communes les villes les
régions
à mon avis c'est tout à fait central
donc les contacts entre le gouvernement
c'est bien mais nécessitent pas il faut
vraiment aussi donc des des milliers de
contact entre entre les Français et les
Allemands les jeunes les plus âgés dans
tous les niveaux alors avec peut-être un
petit bémol sur le rapport Est-Ouest
allemand la France est évidemment plus
proche de de
l'Ouest allemand est-ce qu'il faudrait
peut-être pas un petit peu plus
développé les relations qu'en plus entre
la France et l'Allemagne de l'Est
il y a là aussi également donc de
relations déjà assez access substantiel
n'est-ce pas par exemple la Saxe le nom
de la 5 c'est très intéressant à
renforcer ses relations avec avec les
régions en France c'est aussi vrai pour
la turinge il y a les visites ministres
présidents le Turin il y a quelques mois
ici à Paris
Berlin l'espace et il y a le mélange
entre Belin et Paris qui est qui est
très à qui est très substantiel mais
donc je suis d'accord avec vous en ce
qui concerne les relations entre des
villes les communes ou les régions en
France avec l'Allemagne et l'os on
pourra encore faire mieux
il y a aussi donc les journals vous en
avez parlé 2300 aujourd'hui entre les
différentes institutions entre les
villes les départements les régions
est-ce que il faudrait encore plus de
jumelage ou ce chiffre est plutôt déjà
suffisant il me semble que c'est un
chiffre tout à fait impressionnant
c'est un record n'est-ce pas
quelque chose de pareil n'existe pas
entre deux autres nations dans le monde
donc à mon avis c'est pas seulement la
question du chiffre mais c'est aussi la
qualité de la coopération des décisions
et
de ce point de là il me semble qui est
en ce qui concerne les chimiages il
faudrait se focaliser plutôt donc sur
sur les questions d'avenir vraiment
aussi pour inclure les jeunes c'est à
dire des échanges du sport de la culture
de la musique mais aussi des discussions
ensemble quand est-ce qu'on va surmonter
comment faire face aux défis du futur
qu'est-ce que c'est par exemple la
transition énergétique la transition
numérique digitale ça ce sont des
questions qui n'unissent n'est-ce pas et
il me semble que les chemins sont en
forum idéal en contexte idéal pour
discuter ces questions là en font quoi
allemand j'en profite qu'on a évoqué le
l'Office franco-allemand de la jeunesse
pour préciser que vous avez aussi lancé
récemment un office Germano israélien
pour la jeunesse donc c'est le même
mission que la France développer les
liens entre les deux pays c'est les
mêmes objectifs
une coopération
Germano polonaise pour la jeunesse
l'Allemagne Israël donc c'est la c'est
la l'initiative la plus récente mais le
but est le même le contexte est tout à
fait tout à fait différent avec
l'histoire tragique n'est-ce pas entre
entre l'Allemagne et l'Israël mais le
but est le même n'est-ce pas donc les
jeunes pour discuter donc notre avenir
commun
je retourne sur les relations
franco-allemandes les remarquaise c'est
achevé au lâche Hulse et désormais donc
au pouvoir ce n'est pas le même parti
mais est-ce que ça ça change quelque
chose sur les relations
franco-allemandes donc les personnes
font toujours une différence les smile
de l'autre côté il y a beaucoup de
continuité il y avait ici en France des
questions
donc concernant l'air de d'anglama
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on va continuer
comme d'habitude mais finalement je
pense qu'il y a une
chance et le président de la République
une coopération extrêmement
étroite c'est aussi vrai pour les
ministres donc de ce point de vue là en
ce qui concerne l'intensité de la
coopération il a il a continué
le couple franco-allemand et le moteur
de l'Union européenne est-ce que Macron
et Schulz partage la même vision de
l'Europe
oui
le président Macron il y a quelques
années à prononcer un discours très
important de l'astropone sur la
souveraineté européenne il y a quelques
semaines de chancelier à union discours
très important également à Prague sur sa
vision de l'Europe il a parlé de la
nécessité vraiment de bâtir une Europe
plutôt plus géopolitique plus souveraine
plus capable d'agir donc ça va dans la
même direction que la vision du
président Macron de l'Europe merci
beaucoup
Lucas d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
donc que vous êtes l'ambassadeur
d'Allemagne ici en France et nous on se
retrouve prochainement pour un nouveau
numéro de politique sur Radio sensation
[Musique]